sans donc invité ce soir sur le plateau
Philippe tranchant le directeur de ce
foyer d'accueil médicalisé des réoscourt
et Virginie bernes donc le chef de
service de cet établissement hier soir
mercredi vos résidents étaient sur scène
à mort pas comme des professionnels ils
se sont produits comme de vrais
professionnels et pourtant il souffre de
handicap alors de quel type de handicap
déjà souffre-t-il dans le foyer des réos
accueille 33 personnes adultes
polyhandicapés donc c'est des handicaps
lourds ils sont dépendants dans beaucoup
de choses de la vie quotidienne donc on
les accompagne au quotidien et beaucoup
ne communiquent pas facilement on des
troubles cognitifs ou d'autres troubles
en tout cas beaucoup de troubles moteurs
pour la plupart des handicaps lourds et
pourtant vous avez décidé de les emmener
sur scène alors pourquoi ce choix
d'abord il y a un choix de faire de
nombreuses activités avec eux d'essayer
de les socialiser et de faire des
activités qui puissent leur plaire et
les faire sortir un petit peu de leur
quotidien
le théâtre est une activité qui leur
permet de s'exprimer de communiquer à
leur façon de chanter là c'était une
comédie musicale donc il y avait de la
parole il y avait de
la musique et des danses en fauteuil
pour la plupart mais il y avait aussi
quelques personnes qui marchent qui
étaient dans le sur scène on voit
quelques images justement de ce travail
de répétition c'était juste avant la
représentation du soir ils ont travaillé
pendant 18 mois 18 mois c'est bien ça de
travail intensifs
voilà sur la salle du Centre Social
d'Élancourt et comment s'est passé
l'accompagnement qui s'en est chargé ce
sont les encadrants du foyer des
encadrants se sont fortement mobilisés
pour pour mener ce projet à terme on a
eu trois intervenants extérieurs de
musiciens et une chorégraphe qui ont
participé au projet le projet aimait
comment justement ce sont les résidents
qui voulaient cette comédie musicale
parce que c'est pas la première fois que
vous menez c'est la première fois pour
une comédie musicale
pouvait chanter et chanter en anglais et
chanter en anglais en plus donc il
voulait des difficultés supplémentaires
avons eu des Beatles hier soir sur scène
la représentation qui avait lieu
effectivement hier soir et juste avant
lors de l'ultime filage Johanna bouaker
et le dis-moi ne sont venus réaliser
quelques images et quelques interviews
regardez
le tour du monde en chanson c'est le
thème de la comédie musicale des
résidents des réos à Élancourt des
danses tahitiennes des décors japonais
et des chansons allemandes sont au
programme de la représentation un
spectacle créé interprété par les
personnes en situation de handicap du
foyer médicalisé à Élancourt au total 18
mois de répétition pour une seule
représentation
les 12 personnes sur scène revisitent
des chansons bien connues comme les
Beatles et des musiques bretonnes les
résidents jouent leur propre rôle durant
leur propre tour du monde c'est la
troisième fois que les participants
organisent un spectacle il s'est déroulé
à l'espace Albert Camus de Maurepas
et là nous étions pendant les ultimes à
répétitions et vous me disiez avant de
passer sur ce plateau que c'était encore
mieux hier lors de la grande première de
la représentation ça s'est très très
bien passé c'était magnifique c'est vrai
qu'on avait des décors vidéos des décors
créés par le les actes de plaisir pardon
voilà des costumes et c'était c'était
grand duos ils en parlent encore
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a eu un
débriefing de fait est-ce que il y a un
suivi derrière oui un suivi ils nous ont
déjà demandé quand on recommençait
un retour sur le spectacle avec il y
aura un Facebook des photos de des films
qui ont été faits et nous allons faire
revenir les partenaires qui ont
participé qui nous ont aidé les
professionnels donc pour faire un petit
temps d'échange sur sur ce spectacle qui
a eu lieu quand vous montez un tel
dispositif il y a des subventions des
aides est-ce que ça fait partie de la
des ça fait partie du budget ça fait
partie du budget de l'établissement
voilà on fait avec il faut partager le
budget sur toutes les activités par
rapport à ce cette activité là qui est
plus coûteuse que d'autres bien sûr donc
il y a des choix à faire chaque année
pour pour diversifier un petit peu
toutes les activités que l'on peut faire
j'aimerais qu'on s'attarde un petit peu
sur ce que ça apporte à chacun de ces
résidents justement quel bienfaits ils
en tirent c'est une visée aussi
véritablement thérapeutique même si ça
ne va pas les guérir mais ça leur
apporte beaucoup
déjà il faut dire que au départ notre
objectif c'est de faire quelque chose
avec eux c'est eux qui ont construit le
scénario le thème et qui ont proposé
tout un tas de choses l'objectif n'est
pas de faire un spectacle de
professionnels et tout c'est qui puisse
s'exprimer sur scène et le l'image
corporelle qu'ils ont se trouve amélioré
par rapport à avec un spectacle de ce
type là est-ce qu'il y aura d'autres
représentations c'est une représentation
unique c'est une représentation unique
oui c'est déjà lourd à mettre en place
donc on se contente d'une représentation
il y avait beaucoup de personnes il y
avait 150 personnes à peu près dans la
dans la salle hier soir beaucoup de
familles bien sûr et puis d'autres
établissements du même type que l'on
connaît bien qui sont venus aussi pour
pour applaudir nos jeunes et quand vous
mettez justement en place tout le
travail préparatoire est-ce qu'il y a
des moments aussi qui sont peut-être
plus difficiles que d'autres parce que
là on a l'impression que tout se passe
très bien que c'est c'est presque facile
que tout le monde est moteur motivé mais
il y a peut-être des moments aussi de
frustration de difficultés qui existent
oui ça peut être compliqué certains
moments
il faut gérer la logistique il faut
gérer les plannings aussi pour permettre
aux encadrants participer aux
répétitions donc ils acceptent aussi de
changer chaque jeudi leur jour de
présence les quelques fois c'est
difficile de parce qu'il n'arrive pas à
se dépasser justement et aller au-delà
du handicap parce que le handicap prend
le dessus quelques fois ça peut être
compliqué à certains moments
effectivement
là on est là aussi pour les encourager
pour les soutenir pour aller au bout du
au bout du projet on a la chance d'avoir
aussi des psychologues sur l'institution
qui permettent aussi d'accompagner les
résidents par rapport à ce à cette
représentation quotidien qui se fait un
encadrement de chaque minute pour le
travail de tous les jours et puis en
plus sur ce genre de projet il existe
aussi des des festivals de théâtre pour
personnes en situation de handicap comme
le festival Orphée 11 ans pour ce
festival européen qui va débuter cette
année ce sera le 13 septembre on pourra
d'ailleurs en reparler puisque plusieurs
troupes autour de 50 ans en Yvelines ils
participent vous avez pensé déjà vous y
associer
pour l'instant non on est plutôt
spectateur du festival Orphée on s'y
rend chaque année avec avec les
résidents maintenant effectivement
on est actuellement
aussi bien sur le plan de l'institution
du foyer que de l'association on est sur
une démarche culturelle aussi pour
essayer de s'ouvrir encore plus et de
participer à différentes choses donc ça
fait partie d'un objectif pour cette
année 2013 2014 on verra pourquoi pas et
vous avez prévu déjà le prochain
spectacle
non
souffler un petit peu le débriefing dans
un mois à peu près
d'autres types d'activités qui
permettent de diversifier un petit peu
il faut pas faire ça tous les ans oui
très bien merci à vous deux c'est très
gentil d'être venu nous parler de cette
semaine opération ce spectacle de vos
résidents c'était un Maurepas hier les
images sont aussi revoir dès à présent
sur notre site internet le reportage
complet Merci à VOUS autre sujet tout
aussi festif d'ailleurs le carnaval des
Gatines s'était un plaisir ce week-end
Johanna bouaker et Anthony Reich pour
les images
magicien et acrobates le cirque débarque
à plaisir c'était seulement des
déguisements pour le carnaval des
Gatines à plaisir ça fait seulement deux
ans qu'on a à choisir un thème parce que
pour nous ça nous permet de d'avoir des
un fil rouge pour pouvoir tout organiser
après ça les gens suivent ou pas le
thème cette année on a choisi le cirque
parce que c'est un thème qui est très
porteur c'est très facile de décliner
pour les gens c'est facile de se
déguiser et suivi d'un nez rouge et des
habits n'importe comment il est organisé
comme chaque année par l'association des
résidents des Gatines et du plateau de
plaisir la RGPP c'est du tradition du
quartier d'avoir ce carnaval en revanche
et peut-être la première fois qu'on fait
le carnaval sous la neige habituellement
on le fait en mars cette année on a
voulu faire en février bon voilà on a eu
la neige mais finalement il y a eu
autant de personnes que d'habitude au
programme de cette année flash mob
spectacle de danse et une grande
nouveauté un spectacle de magie